aujourd'hui c'est déjà fait trois
librairies et dans les trois librairies
en avait déjà plus donc là c'est
peut-être mon dernier espoir c'est un
choc émotionnel c'est beaucoup de choses
vraiment genre marivaux sent déjà c'est
vraiment une grande aventure ça a bercé
notre enfance j'achète les tomes depuis
2004 des messins qu'à peu près et c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'exceptionnel
bonjour librairie accoucha
malheureusement il nous reste très peu
de quantité et nous prenons strictement
qu'une réservation ça sera premier
arrivé premier servi
c'est une série que
qui touche beaucoup de générations et
qui a une certaine popularité qui fera
que ça sera sans doute la meilleure et
peut-être l'unique série de l'auteure
one piece une passion française parce
que c'est la première série de manga
atteindre son tome sans donc déjà un
tome sens en soi c'est suffisamment
emblématique lorsque vous regardez les
volumes de vente on a one piece
représente plus de 8% des ventes de
l'ensemble des titres de manga
alors le one piece c'est une sorte de
légende toute l'histoire commence avec
gold rogers surnommé le roi des pirates
et il était surnommé le roi des pirates
parce que justement il avait tout il
avait trouvé le one piece gaulle rogers
a été ensuite arrêté par la marine et
exécutés et sauf que ce qui devait être
on va dire simplement l'exécution d'un
du roi des pirates donc un acte pour un
acte de d'envergure pour la marina en
réalité ouvert l'ère de la piraterie
puisque au moment de mourir gold rogers
a dit mon trésor je vous le laisse il
est tout ce dont un homme peut rêver et
donc c'est à partir de là que se sont
élancés une multitude de pirates à
travers les mers de de l'univers de one
piece pour justement trouvé ce one piece
mais on ne sait pas encore quoi il
s'agit
au revoir